roses Zen Rosie who was fixing your hair
was that your girlfriend rules the
Flocka get over here for me come at this
mark okay let me get into first how you
felt tonight - when - the women actually
I thought they gave you a lot of love I
thought they'd come at you more cuz all
season long they did yeah they did and I
appreciate that so much I wasn't
necessarily expecting that but just
hearing from a lot of the women just
hearing all those really sweet kind
words of encouragement why not it was
amazing it was okay let's dig into how
things are ending Madison has given you
an ultimatum watching this footage back
how do you feel watching it do you feel
it was fair that she kept some things
from you and gave you this decision to
make I keep getting asked that and I
don't feel like it was an ultimatum I
don't I think it was her doing what I
asked every girl to do from the very
first night and that was to be honest to
me and share what was ever on their
heart and that's what she did and it
trust me it made it for an insanely
incredibly difficult week for me there's
no doubt about that but I can't fault
her for sharing her heart she seemed to
almost say no to the rose what if she
had I've been a person like bachelor
history that have been Navin Roth what
do you do there how does your season end
Peter well if you must know you guys
continue in a couple weeks if I got bark
crying about Peter a lot of people think
it's Hannah brown now coming in possibly
jewels of Locker who knows there's so
many I'm glad you brought up your
producers name she's your producer is
she the woman that you're with right now
so many theories out there right now
it's it's been it's kind of crazy to
hear but I don't know we'll see you
absolutely know well here's the thing
maybe you don't I don't know I don't
know if you heard this but at the
beginning of the tell-all Chris Harrison
said this is an ending where no one
knows how it will end
not even Peter there is not a single
person who knows how Peters journey will
in not even Peter do you not know how's
your season ends
it's definitely a chance about that yeah
help me understand things just are you
know they continue to unfold until the
very last second and I don't know when
that last second occurred so does that
mean that right now you might be unclear
on someone's feelings for you on if
you're in a relationship that's what it
sounds like man you love to push this
yeah you guys will see I just learned so
much I could say but it all I could say
is again it was it was the toughest
toughest last week for sure of my life
and see if that means you know your own
romantic status right now on my way do
you know your own romantic status right
now I guess what the two day good
teasing hey he said it not me
alright are you really in love with
three women you've gotten some criticism
for this yeah I don't I don't know why
it's if I wasn't feeling I wouldn't have
said it so again I've always been a firm
believer a little heart wants what it
wants and I think this experience for
sure is show me there's not just one
soul mate out there I think at some
point of my life I used to think that
and yeah I've definitely been able to
give my heart to more than one person so
it's possible are you with your soul
mate now speaking of the heart wanting
what it wants
Peter why do you want crazy
I don't want crazy Peter you said you
did that's hunter hey saying that That's
not me I was just singing along the
lyrics okay I listen our relationship
with with my flute Victoria it was very
real there was a lot of crazy there I
think I said once with Hannah brown like
a little bit crazy as fun just a little
bit not a lot I swear
watching things back with Victoria a lot
of people have said look this is really
dysfunctional how are you feeling
watching it back anything you would do
differently what's just your take on I
think you saw a relationship there that
definitely required a lot of work and we
could definitely easily given up really
early on and it would have been a lot
easier for pie that both of us but I
think there's something beautiful and
that we did it and even though there's a
lot of opinions about people that think
we should never have been together we
fought and fought and fought and I think
till the end even though it wasn't us in
the end I thought there was something
beautiful of that relationship and have
what it got the point it got to and what
we learned about ourselves and just
being able to communicate a lot better
I really appreciate
who was the hardest goodbye you haven't
seen that yet trying to kill me you're
trying to kill me and you might kill
your own mother worried at all costs
Victoria F surprised everybody tonight
she came in communicating clearly
speaking her mind we loved watching it
how did you feel seeing what kind of
felt like a different woman out there
yeah that was a very beautiful thing for
me to see and there's you know even if
maybe you don't find your person
throughout this it's only gonna work for
hopefully two people there's a lot to be
learned and I feel like I learned a lot
too but seeing that with Victoria just
it made me so happy to see her in a good
spot and you know she deserves love just
like every single person here last
question anything that you're sorry for
that you would do differently hearing
from the women tonight looking back at
the season I you know I heard a couple
things today
you know tonight with maybe I wasn't
able to give enough time to it some of
the woman because some of the drama you
know took up a lot of that time and that
for that I'm sorry
that was never my intention but I have
to get myself some self grace because I
didn't do that on purpose I was just
trying to follow my heart and do what I
could do in that moment I don't really
like to say regrets it's mistakes I
learn from oh I have one more I'm sorry
I forgot this a lot of people were
saying why didn't you push for more on
the accusation that Victoria had broken
up relationships do you wish you'd ask
more questions gotten more clarity on
that because she's sitting there telling
you I don't know what to answer to yeah
and I did and it just unfortunately
wasn't able to air but we had a long
conversation about really what her
relationship was with Marissa and
accusations she was making we talked
about the relationships that that
Marissa had brought up and there's a
reason why I made my decision you know I
wasn't just going off and no no
conversation there we had a long
conversation and in regards to that with
Marissa and my relationship that wasn't
very serious at all I maybe seen her for
four times throughout the course of a
month it was a lot more serious with
Victoria and so when I heard Victoria
side of the story it was enough for me
to make the decision and I felt good
about it
Peter I keep seeing that you make what I
call 747 statements the most perfect
girl the best first date ever
how do you say these extreme things
and not pick unohana and who's the most
perfect girl Han is she is a very no
one's perfect but she's very close to
perfect
I'm a very passionate dude and I'm an
extremist kind of and so I make these
statements and it comes from the heart
and that's just who I am
flying high in a 747 Peter that's my
theory airplane I love that you know
that look at
[Music]